what was the point of filming that hey
what's up guys my name is the chana
welcome back to another one of these
hazel development vlogs first of all
what a crazy time it is welcome to all
the new viewers who saw my playstation 5
and Unreal Engine reaction videos I have
no idea that they would get as much
attention as they did in fact it's kind
of scary like with all the news articles
being written about me
quoting me misquoting me all that stuff
to be honest I'm kind of happy that that
is over and I can get back just
peacefully working on hazel teach you
guys how to make a game engine C++ all
the fun kind of stuff that I used to do
here before so glad to be back the whole
kind of premise of this little video is
it's it's kind of a little bit more of
like an update video both I mean I mean
these are like dev locks of course
they're update videos but I specifically
want to talk about the game engine
series because this is something that
has been at the back of my mind slowly
creeping its way forward and it's just
it's something that just make this a
little bit darker maybe it's something
that that I feel is not I'm not happy
with how the game engine series is going
now I made a post like a little
community person here on YouTube just
talking about the fact that I was like
rethinking my strategy for the series
because guys here's here's the deal and
when I say guys I mean guys and girls so
here's the thing I'm not just making the
game engine series I'm also developing
hazel as a standalone engine auto people
actually know that it's quite difficult
to find that balance between me actually
creating things working on my own
technology learning new things and then
also having to kind of teach that in a
way that first of all is very time
consuming because building a game engine
is it's a lot of hard work it takes a
lot of time and if I have to show all of
that in video format that is even longer
especially with the way that I was
usually working on the game engine
series episodes which in the ones where
I actually have to explain things and
teach things I used to kind of you know
sit myself down I would go through the
code I'd write it offline not being
required onto a video at all I would
basically come up with a good solution
to the problem as well as think through
a good explanation then I would revert
the code and then I would type it live
kind of in front of a camera whilst
recording and explaining everything that
is going on now that's great and I think
it creates a pretty decent series but
the problem is that as everything gets
more complex and I'm just one person I
don't have a team I don't have like a
bunch of employees who I can delegate
this work to and be like okay well I
need you to like do basically everything
you can to bring the game engine series
up to scratch while I actually work on
hazel or while I actually make a save us
lost video or do something else
basically what I'm trying to say is the
game engine series is kind of becoming a
burden so it's cancelled no I'm kidding
it's not cancelled at all don't worry
what I'm going to do with the game
engine series is I'm going to change the
format up a little bit I'm basically
going to make it into a live stream but
it's not gonna be live bear with me I am
going to sit down in front of a computer
I'm going to hit record on the camera
and I'm going to literally just work on
hazel I'll be explaining everything I'm
doing along the way I'll be using the
occasional diagram if I feel that an
explanation requires it I will be
effectively going through my whole
thought process and everything that I'm
doing in that current episode now I'm
going to know what I'll be doing mostly
because you know I mean I've been
working on hazel offline off the cameras
for hazel Deb is the 3d version of hazel
I've been working on that for a long
time so I obviously know the next steps
for the game engine series which is
significantly behind but the point is
what I'll be doing is everything will
just be filmed live I'll be going
through the whole thought process as I
just work on the 2d version of the
public game series game engine series
version of hazel everything will just be
right there in front of you all I'm
going to edit all of that down into
hopefully a 30 to 40 minute episode at
the most and I'm gonna obviously cut out
all the boring bits or if there's
certain bits where I literally like have
to debug for 10 minutes and it's really
boring I might either fast forward that
cut it out right over the top of that I
will see how it works out because I
haven't filmed any of these yet but that
is going to be the basic idea now what
I'm hoping this will do is first of all
it's going to make the series more
enjoyable for me to make because at the
moment I'll be honest with you guys I've
always tried to be as honest as possible
with you guys pretty much every week
when it rolls around to like a Thursday
or so and it's time for me to record a
game engine series video I am just
filled with dread because I know that
that's going to be some downtime that's
gonna stop me from working on like hazel
dev and doing doing stuff that I guess
to me is more useful and yeah like I'm
sure that sounds selfish because it just
sounds like I want my life to be fun but
it's more or less just that the fact
that it's taking up a lot of time and I
feel like that time is better spent
elsewhere now on the flip side I think
that the way that the series is I mean
especially the last few episodes well
we'll talk about that in a minute
but I just feel like the way that the
series is it I'm not sure how enjoyable
it is for people to watch I think
personally it would be a lot more
enjoyable if I just sat down and it was
like kind of like a fun kind of let's
work on a project together and I'll
share my ideas with you and I will guide
you through it the whole way just kind
of sitting down and working on it live
it'll be like someone going to their
workshop and then building something in
front of the camera and just talking
through everything they're doing like
that's fun that's a lot more fun than
going into the workshop making the thing
that you're trying to make then
basically breaking it apart or just
building another one in front of the
camera like I just feel like that's a
little bit unnatural and I just I just
don't like the way that it is now in
regards to the previous couple episodes
what I did with with the game engine
series then is I try to make it more fun
and I said that to you guys I said that
I'm you know I'm trying to make this
more fun so let's build a little game
together now I kind of regret doing that
to be honest because first of all I
don't think hazel was at the point where
I'm making a game like that is gonna be
fun but more importantly it's not gonna
be a it's not gonna be at all reflective
of the actual workflow to make a game in
hazel because that's not how I imagine
people will be making games in hazel
that's kind of just like taking a little
bit of the core of hazel and then
building a game on top of that I feel
like it's basically useless and a
complete waste of time so we're
completely scrapping that idea what
we're going to be doing
for hazel 2d and the game engine series
is we are going to be essentially
creating I should say the priority of
that series at the moment is going to be
to create a full 2d workflow on all
platforms what that means is that you
should be able to open up hazel make a
game in 2d and then both make it and
publish it onto all platforms by all
platforms I mean desktop platforms for
now so that includes Windows Mac and
Linux probably in that order of priority
now what does that full workflow mean
that's something that is probably going
to require another video but also
something that we're probably not fully
aware of because until we start actually
until we create like a workflow and then
go through it and then realize oh why
don't we do this instead or this would
be better the workflow is going to
evolve is gonna change and it's not
worth like defining in stone at the
beginning whatsoever but essentially
what I mean is you should be able to
open up hazel as like there should be
like a tool like a level editor or
something like that you should be able
to open that up you should be able to
drag a bunch of assets in like textures
and like animations and sound clips and
all of that stuff you should be able to
write a little script and create a bunch
of entities and add some components to
them you know using that actual like
editor tool you should be able to write
a script in like c-sharp and attach it
to a given entity and that should just
function and then finally you should be
able to export that as a standalone game
or standalone application that can run
outside of the editor that is what I
mean by full workflow and you have to be
able to do that on Windows Mac and Linux
that is where the game engine series is
heading right now that is the top
priority that is also the top priority
of hazel dev hazel dev is the kind of 3d
patreon only kind of version of hazel
that I'm writing in my spare time
outside of the game engine series that
right now and I'm about to show you what
that contains as of right now by the way
that's what this weekly weekly kind of
update is about as well but that's also
the priority of that so that's what I'll
be doing all of the work which I will
then eventually basically live kind of
read
right I guess as part of the game engine
series whilst also explaining everything
in detail as I'm doing it but
essentially I'm gonna take that and I'm
gonna create that full 2-d workflow
inside
hazal 3d and that's gonna be you know
live streamed on the patreon live
streams and all of that kind of stuff
that is the current plan let me know
what you guys think of both the format
of the series changing as well as the
direction of what we're trying to
achieve leave a comment below let me
know what your thoughts are I'm
personally really excited for it and
part of the motivation for this is
because as much as I love game engines
and let's be honest i i do love making
game engines quite a lot the creative
kind of side of me I feel is starving a
little bit because there's a lot of code
there's a lot of like designing
workflows and just you know programming
like the base technology there's a lot
of that and there's not much actual
content creation I want to start using
hazel to make things I want to make the
game engine series like the hazel 2d I
want to make that something that you
people can use to make content and to
make games as soon as possible
that is what I'm focusing on right now I
want to make it like a full-on like
editor and everything so that you can
basically use it almost like unity to
make something you know from scratch and
then kind of publish it in some kind of
format you know on github or something
but like what I mean is like a
standalone thing outside of any tools
and outside of any edit ISM and all that
stuff that is what I'm focusing on
because I want to start actually
creating content for it as part of that
drive to create content as well me and
my wife have actually started working on
a little game as well if you guys want
to see a little bit more of that let me
know but like it's very early days I'll
probably end up showing it in some dev
logs in the future we've just started
kind of brainstorming like an art and
art aesthetic I guess and a few other
things but it's basically gonna be like
some kind of story driven like 2d game
you know more on that later but that is
all part of my kind of commitment to
actually create content for hazel
because at the end of the day even
though I am a software engineer I'm also
like an artist at heart and a content
creator and
I really feel like that part of me is
kind of starving and in need of actual
creativity anyway I hope that you
enjoyed this little kind of rant I'll
see you next week with another one
probably let me know what you guys are
thinking in the comment section below
you know we're a community and I really
do value all of your comments and all of
your thoughts I read all of them on
these death blogs I promise I'm super
excited I think that's ultimately the
best direction to take this and tomorrow
when I record the game in the next
episode of the game engine serious I'm
actually looking forward to that because
I'm just gonna sit down and we're gonna
probably start working on the edits I'm
going to start working on like the Edit
I'm gonna bring in like the IM GUI
docking library we're gonna set up like
a dock space we're going to make like a
viewport for our actual game view and
our scene view and we'll kind of talk
about that and we're going to kind of
just start working on that and it's just
gonna be me working on it like and
filming it it's not gonna be like me
having to spend a day trying to
basically like set up a theatrical
production like performance for you guys
of me perfectly writing code without
making mistakes which doesn't even
happen like most of the time it's just
gonna be it's gonna be fine we're just a
hangout we're just gonna work on this
project together and I think it's gonna
be so much fun and who knows maybe I'll
even make it live at some point but the
reason I don't want to actually
livestream it is because I feel like
there will be a lot of kind of dead time
there and I would like to cut that out
and make it like you know a little bit
more I still want to make it a fairly
polished product but just maybe a little
bit more relaxed and you know a little
bit more spontaneous because I think
that's also a really good way to
actually I guess teach people a bit more
and show people what the actual kind of
workflow and like what actual like you
know what actually making this thing is
like and also the problems we might
encounter along the way I think it'll be
beneficial to fix them in front of
people as well anyway
let's dive in and take a look at a hazel
dev so this is a 3d version of hazel
it's available for patrons of course
patron come for sight returned oh by the
way is the best way to help support
hazel the game engine series this whole
channel my whole life you guys made the
trail it's worth noting that like I
think I mentioned a month ago that for
the month of May I'm going to make live
streams like Half Price
if you guys like her a five-dollar
patron you'll get access to all of the
live streams i stream weekly for like
several hours of me working on hazel dev
I've decided to just keep it $5.00
forever
because I was really happy with all the
new people that came as a result of that
and it's just you know it's just nice to
share the last race with more people so
if you guys do you want to support me
and all of this stuff that I'm doing
then definitely check that out we always
have a really good time and it's always
fun to kind of build this stuff as well
so anyway let's just let's dive in and
take a look at what's new okay so where
do I begin there are actually quite a
number of new features first of all let
me just move this out of the way I
changed the gizmos a little bit this is
probably the most like minor feature but
I change the gizmos a little bit just
made them a little bit fatter I quite
like this rotation gives me I was kind
of inspired by blenders rotation gizmo
it's kind of just kind of just looks at
you wherever you are and it you know you
can see the lines moving it just looks
pretty cool I think the way that we
currently move anta t is don't mind the
bounding box selection currently I don't
actually have a bounding box for the
entity or any kind of selection feedback
so I'm just displaying the currently
selected meshes kind of bounding box
just to give some feedback as to what's
selected but if you look at this very
temporary button in this very temporary
location that says entity what this
actually does is if I click it it
switches between entity and mesh this is
what you're selecting so if I select
this this is a separate entity here I
can move it around if I select this I
can move the entity around but if I
change it to mesh mode I can now
actually move around like these
individual meshes so you can see I can
move just like the sphere for example or
just the current or something like that
and if I switch back to entity mode now
I can move everything so this is just a
way to edit the sub meshes within a mesh
now you can now also kind of when you
click on this you'll see there's a scene
hierarchy and a properties panel when I
click on this it contextually selects
like the properties will change to
whatever the selection context is so we
have this and we have this now the most
interesting thing here is probably this
new noise looking texture here what I've
been doing is I've been following
Sebastian's like procedural land
generation tutorial have a link in the
description
but I'm sure you guys have heard of it
this is like I really like all of his
videos he has some amazing like code
adventure videos but the point is
there's one series that he has where
he's building this kind of procedural
land generation and he's doing sorry in
unity what I've been doing is basically
following that series but in hazel which
is interesting concept and it's kind of
a cool idea I had that I really actually
liked the sound of because it basically
means that I can somewhat work to what's
creating something that might be
possible in unity and also making that
all dynamic so if I select this what you
can see is first of all we have a script
attached to it we have the example map
generator script now if I open the map
generator scripts this is what it is
it's a c-sharp script with a bunch of
random stuff here and half this code is
actually just me testing like the
certain script functions and working
correctly such as house component gate
component but the point is what we have
is we have an on create function on this
map generator class and that's what gets
called when the entity gets created that
calls generate map which is this
function and then we basically create a
noise map this is another C sharp script
if you check out his tutorial in the
description below you'll see that this
code is pretty much almost identical and
that's kind of the point you know we're
trying to recreate the same thing but in
hazel here we're creating a texture and
then filling it with a bunch of colors
and setting the daughter of the texture
here we have a mesh component that we're
trying to retrieve this is just testing
what happens if you don't have the mesh
component because we don't have a mesh
component on the entity when we create
the the entity in C++ it doesn't have a
mesh component so this returns null we
then create a mesh component this is
just us testing being able to create
components through scripts we're then
setting the mesh to be mesh factory to
create plane which creates that plane
mesh for us we're setting the transform
of the entity and then we're actually
setting this material to have this
texture now this is this kind of this
exact code is very very like you know
rough and it won't be like this at all
because you can see we're having to
retrieve the material at index 1 that's
because the plane mesh that we're
creating the plane from you know it has
it's like the index 1 because mesh
factory cry plane at the moment is
actually loading like an obj file that I
just happened to have because I wanted
to get this in as fast as possible and
already how that stuff this will
eventually just construct the actual
vertices like you
card instead of doing that ridiculous
thing anyway that's why we have like
albedo text toggle it's also currently
going through the PBR shader and not
through like an omlette material or
something that you would generally want
to use very early days so this will
change quite a lot but I just wanted to
show you how this works one of the
coolest things that I've actually done
this this week because most of this
script stuff was done last week this
week I added public fields being exposed
to the editor just like in unity so
basically map with map higher octaves
all this stuff you can see that there
public integers right there public
fields so what happens is if something
is public like this and I might change
this to like require an attribute or
something if you actually want to expose
I'm not sure I'm playing around with it
you can see this to do as well I want
certain things to show up in certain
ways but the point is all of these
public fields are over here and you can
change any of them now because this is
created on the oncreate function right
this isn't something that gets updated
these actually don't get updated until
you run on create again that's why I had
this little run script button this just
calls the oncreate function again so in
other words if i zoom in here a little
bit if I change this to like 256 by 256
maybe I'll you know change the seed and
I hit run script first of all the answer
is gonna move back to its original
location because gonna rerun the script
it's not gonna recreate the entity but
it's going to rerun the script and the
real reason that it's actually snapping
back to there is because we're actually
setting the transform to be a certain
thing like in this case we're setting
the transform to be a scale of 10 with
no translation so because we're setting
the transform were effectively resetting
it back to be here if you got rid of
this then obviously wouldn't the entity
wouldn't actually move now if I you know
let's see what else can we do here let's
change the seed I'll hit run script
again you know we can change like the
offset is the vector that's exposed we
have a noise scale that we can also run
here anyway the point is you can set
this through whatever you like we're on
the script it's all really cool now if
you have a script so there's some you
know this this test entity here for
example this script which is example
does script which if I find that it's
this thing here you can see this has a
public float speed and the speed is
actually used in the on update function
that's even better because it means that
I can just you know use the arrow keys
like before to remove this entity but
then if I just increase
the speed here I don't have to do
anything right it's just going to run
faster because obviously that variable
is being used inside the on update
function so yeah pretty cool stuff I'm
really happy with this I need to keep
following this tutorial probably and
hopefully we'll end up with some
procedural landmass completely generated
in hazel there are still a lot of things
that I want to do like you know we
should be able to have like an asset
manager and be able to create materials
and then drag the material and here for
example and that would be our unlit
material because at the moment as I
mentioned this is actually being used as
the PBR material so you can see we can
change this and it also is influenced by
this kind of you know skybox environment
map and all that stuff and by a camera
exposure and all of that stuff which is
probably something you wouldn't want for
just you know a little texture entity
like this but yeah that's there so that
is how that stuff works and that's what
I've been working on this past week
mostly just getting all of these kind of
public fields exposed like this
so hopefully that gave you guys a little
bit of an insight into what is new
inside hazel dev remember if you want
access to the source code and live
streams and check out patreon and come
for the churner I'm really excited about
this stuff if you're worried that
Hazel's turning into unity then please
don't be I just think it's a nice first
step to kind of establish what people
already you know say is a very easy
intuitive workflow and then work from
there to improve it so what I'm doing is
basically making sure that it is at
least as easy to follow Sebastian's
tutorial in hazel as it is in unity and
then from there we're going to add some
cooler features and make this a
completely new experience it's just I
think it's just a good starting point
hope you guys enjoyed this video a
little bit of a hazel dev slash game
engine serious catch up I will see you
tomorrow with the new game engine series
episode and I mean there's so much other
stuff I want to talk about that I still
have it in fact in the last hazel dev
vlog that take it slow one I talked
about you know the e CS and c-sharp and
how there's just so much stuff that I
still want to talk about if you guys
want to see those videos let me know and
I'll try and make them a little bit
quicker but there's just there's so much
that I guess learned and discovered as
part of the process of getting you know
an EC a sensation
and all of this stuff into hazel Deb
that I'd love to share with you guys and
it probably will pretty soon but thank
you for watching love you all goodbye
[Music]
[Music]